welcome to the greatest movie ever
podcast
I'm your host definition each month I'm
joined by a guest to discuss their
favorite film in all its silver-screen
cinematic scope as this is our first
episode I wanted to cover a film that I
absolutely adore which is the shining
but before we get into that I'd like to
introduce a man I've known for several
years you stir it in blood for uni lad
don't flop I'm just hundreds and
hundreds of sites that he's helped to
really grow and push it's a man who are
pretty much see post something shining
related once a week he's a huge fan and
it's great to have him on the show so
how are you doing bent legs I'm 8 yeah
I'm good cheers mate as a glowing
glowing introduction I wasn't expecting
anything that nice well I didn't want to
talk about the drug addiction you know
what I mean this is a good way to start
and so obviously you a massive fan of
The Shining do you remember when you
first saw it now it's kind of one of
those movies that that's sort of
ingrained in the public consciousness I
think yeah I think the first time I
watched it I was probably a kid right
yeah teenager and I just kind of thought
well that wasn't I don't know like at
that time I was really big on films like
the Evil Dead yeah I'd like that
splattery
kind of thing and cuz the shining didn't
really have that at that time I kind of
dismissed it yeah so I don't remember
the first time I watched it I remember
re watching it as I got a little bit
older maybe like 18 19 20 yeah see I'm
just at 11 and I remember absolutely
[ __ ] myself I think that was like
the last nightmare that I had I just
vividly remember like being in bed
terrified
but it is interesting that you kind of
didn't like it because the shining did
get really bad reviews yeah when it came
out I mean Kubrick obsessed over doing
different versions of this film like Tom
Cruise used to joke that Cooper
was still editing The Shining in between
nice white shirt I do remember being
really scared it was an embarrassing age
to be to be scared and you know it just
really stuck with me
and I think the more you delve into it
the more you kind of become obsessed
over it yeah yeah that's definitely what
it was like for me like the first time I
watched it I think I watched it with
like like a few of my friends like we
always used to like hang out on weekends
over Easter yeah watch all these mad
films and be movies and stuff like that
but because I was watching it with like
a group of people mm-hmm I wasn't really
absorbing it taking it inner it's not
strange because it has got this like
very hypnotic atmosphere to it I mean I
was watching it the other day and it
just kind of sucks you and I think it's
like the longshots yeah have you seen
the two different versions of the film
I've seen the American warning years ago
mm-hmm and I know that we mentioned it
the other week and I just haven't been
able to find yeah extended version over
there I remember the only thing I
remember really is it's about is it like
15 20 minutes longer if that I mean it's
very few extra shots yeah and it's like
a few bits that just kind of I think he
said it himself like he's basically
dumbing it down for the American
audience yeah there's a lot more kind of
explain and they go more into the the
Red Robin sort of thing and there's a
definitely confirms that there's ghosts
in the hotel like these skeletons and is
really not very good and it's strange
because normally I always prefer the
longer version of films bar maybe Leon
the professional and this yeah works
better when it's condensed to two hours
horrors in general I kind of think two
hours is like the maximum they can go
because you kind of lose these scares a
bit they they can go too far into it as
well yeah exactly that's what I like
about the shining is there there's no
definite
it's yeah so so so there's no definite
ending like this there's loads of
different theories and the reason it's
so good or so debatable is because all
of these theories you can fit the me
yeah exactly and I've just been going
over some of the theories I mean Rob age
does an absolutely fantastic one his
YouTube channel is pretty much full of
just amazing shining reviews and
analysis and it's yeah he's really
really good so definitely stuff for this
for my notes yeah I've seen is one the
common words cool but it's about Danny
and the bear cross yeah I've got quite a
few notes on that em it's about like the
child abuse of yeah motif it's quite
dark but well we'll get into that later
did you know originally that this film
was shot square yes a TV and then it's
been in Kubrick was kind of he was angry
about that and he didn't want people
cutting his movie and so he made a
widescreen version as well and that's
why the blu-ray version is very it's it
is cutting elements off but it it's an
it doesn't have the black bars along the
top that you often get with cinematic
blu-rays and there's a whole controversy
behind like just the way that Kubrick
shot everything so when he went to film
it everything's very much within a tight
square because he knew that people would
cut it to a square yeah but it just it
really adds to the claustrophobia that
the feeling that everything sort of
centered around the middle he did that a
lot with loads of films denier yeah like
that I remember the name of the words
for the perspective where everything's
kind of like in the poor letterbox is
normal in it yeah it said there's like a
word for the perspective where it's
basic like a cuboid going in so like the
four corners meet they all go towards
the middle and in the middle is where it
happens so like yeah you look through
any of his films I think yeah bar
probably Spartacus I don't think it
- watching but especially like there's
definitely loads of it in 2001 a chronic
conference where it all points towards
the middle it gives you it's like it's
almost like a tunnel vision yeah
definitely yeah which I quite like and I
think that it lends itself to the shine
in really well because like you say that
claustrophobia like even now when I
watch it the certain things that make me
feel a bit confused or weird about like
are quite pinpoint what it is so did you
ever read the book I tried to know what
I tried reading it yeah years ago I
might try reading it again now and it
was so different and what I didn't like
about it was it's basically everything
that the film isn't yeah there's huge
differences I mean kupah pretty much
took the plot and then wanted yeah I
know that I know that Stephen King
didn't like it because like I know that
there's that the main differences is
like in the book the evil comes from
like outside yeah so there's like
outside influences the house itself and
wherever and then like the film
Kubrick's made the evil come from like
Jack yeah and I think Jack's character
if I remember correctly Jack's character
in the book was a lot more um I don't
know sympathetic is the right word the
word that looking for but his carrot
that was a lot less a lot more man I was
not just a psychopath yeah from the very
beginning yeah and I I know that the
ending of the books different because in
the book the ending is the hotel blow up
or catch fire yeah something like that
where is it a film obviously the hotel
freezers yeah so so like I like that
he's kind of gone well you know what
yeah your endings alright what I'm just
gonna do a new one with rising yeah and
not tell anyone what it means
well King slammed Kubek version and he
actually made his own and
did have a lot of shots back and forth
like the king version is absolutely
terrible I remember was it straight to
TV yeah it was yeah and it's been shown
on channel 5 several times yeah I saw it
it was even though light really is not
because that's what King wanted yeah
okay King was actually contracted to
write a film script and but Kubrick
wasn't contracted to film it so Kubrick
pretty much throughout King's draft and
brought in what he called an actual
seriousness and to write his script with
them so yeah they kind of had a fallin
now over the years King has recently
admitted that he does like The Shining
but I think that's just people but on
the surface it is a really just a
simplistic plot I mean a man goes to a
hotel
he gets cabin fever he tries to murder
his family he's an alcoholic he hit
student he ruined his career and he sort
of needs this chance to to revive his
career and that's why they have to stay
in the hotel but everything just sort of
goes haywire um but it's a brilliant
like setting for a horror movie and I
remember anything before this I mean
would you ever go to the Overlook Hotel
I'd love to go you know what I weird
thing is they M there isn't actually a
room 237 at the Overlook Hotel because
they thought it would scare people off
yeah it's like 2 1 7 years to 107 year
yeah apparently like because I don't a
what I like surely more people would
want to go if they had a room 237 yeah
well apparently the truth of room 2 1 7
is the most requested room in that hotel
mm-hmm cuz it's not it's not called the
Overlook is it it's called caramel white
school it's called something else yeah
or yeah like I yeah I'd say in me I've
got a room I've got a room I've got a
237 time oh great yeah so I've got like
yeah I've got the axe and the blood
coming off it the blood spells like 237
woman off it well that kinda goes into
my next point which is like the legacy M
of The Shining like have you ever
watched Hannibal yes so many marshes in
that I mean they watched it quite
recently and that's sort of what made me
want to do the shining first they have
like an episode where they rebuilt the
bathroom set and there's aspects of the
the carpet appears an American Horror
Story I mean it's a very gameis carpet
pattern I've got the carpet pattern tie
there's a background fracture but I've
got the in your room 237 the carpet is
like a bib it's like a purple like half
circle repeating on itself I've actually
got a hat there's a brand called casual
connoisseur that they do stuff it's
mainly for like 40 lads and stuff but
they have a lot of cultural references
and they brought out but they brought
out a few but they brought out one the
orange one the orange the iconic carpet
was in Tweed stories that carpet okay
yeah yeah when they go next door to
share the carpets there it's just like
such an iconic carpet isn't it yeah I've
noticed it in so many films and I was
like my girlfriend I've got everything
I've got like I'm literally looking at
my xbox now and I've got a skin for my
xbox and the controller of the carpet
I've got like a mountain man I've got
patches that I've got all sorts of stuff
yeah everything she didn't related but
yeah like that carpet in what I talking
about fears like cultural references
that was yes I casual kind of see
released at the Hat but they only
release like I don't know say like 40 or
50 at a time and they're like 35 quid
it's like a bobble hat that Rob folds up
it's got the carpet covers the carpet
colors and everything and then like a
blue bobble on the top yeah they go on
sale they'll announce when it's going on
sale it doesn't look like I think two or
three runs I know but like oh it's going
on sale at one o'clock this one might
wanna clock seven o'clock only made one
minute past seven there on eBay 450
creddie yeah it's light
I just cannot get hold of them for
loving the money but like they released
all sorts of stuff but like yeah like
the cultural references that it's in
everything the shine in it the reference
I think more than anything I've ever I
don't know whether it's cuz I've noticed
it more cuz I'm the fan of it yeah so I
see things that other people may not see
they might just think I was two girls
you know I mean whereas I'm no that's
that's W the girls from the shiny no
that's the carpet or that's the the kid
kind of like riding his bike whatever
you know whatever is and I I think our
first became aware of it when it was
parodied in The Simpsons I was about to
say I knew Simpsons then it's been
parallel it parodied a few times in that
I think I mean even on passengers which
came out quite recently that's got like
a similar sort of bartender many things
that just have like the shining within
them it's amazed how much it gets used
for such as for a film that so many
people hated it fits having yeah but I
mean it's it's great because now so many
people obsess over it and it's because
of the work that Kubrick put into it and
I think like the The Shining holds the
record for the most amount of takes of
any scene yeah the year is it the common
up that's gone up the stairs scene isn't
it where she swept Wendy's swinging the
bat well there's a one that was quite a
lot and there's the guy whose mind
getting a mind blank yeah um the mystic
guy who has the shining as well
O'Halloran yeah he he broke down and
cried because he had to do 187 takes on
something I think the blood elevator
scene they shot twice and that was the
only thing that they did in less than 10
takes and it's just crazy that that's
the thing that they shot the least mad
in it like I saw a thing like I watched
a video on youtube I can't remember
which one because there's hundreds but
there was one and it was about that
elevator scene yeah
and I didn't notice it until it got
pointed out have you noticed like you
know in the
what kind of comes in and kind of
splashes it's all in slow motion on the
left-hand side as we look at it there's
what looks like a body backdrops with it
right okay like in in the broad I like I
don't know what that is weather like
that's what they've used they've used a
bag or something to store the blood or
something let it drop or that's what
moved so we could drop in because like
it looks like a body bag in that but
it's so weird I didn't notice it until
like it got pointed out that's what I
liked about the film there's so many
things I'm like right that's what it is
something that's why it doesn't make
sense you know something doesn't make
sense and then it gets explaining like
ah yeah well one of the the big things
that doesn't make sense about the film
is the layout of the hotel yeah they try
to recreate the layout of it in it you
can you can level yes do it because it's
just absolutely like crazy like what I
love that Kubrick does is it gives you
this feeling that there's something
wrong with in the hotel but you can't
put your finger on it because it's so
subtle as well there's no explanation to
so many things like one of the things I
like most is you know that big room that
he's in like that he sits and does it's
working with his typewriter ooh yeah Wow
so like as he sit where he sits he sits
opposite the stairs yeah on the
right-hand side of hims like a big
window all the way along and the room is
like really really tall room it's enough
for two probably three stories really
yeah but when they go up the stairs on
turn right they can turn right again
yeah it's a corridor that like wouldn't
be there at first because obviously the
wind you can see out the window you know
there's nothing there but also when he's
going down there so he's gone off he's
turned right he's turned right again on
the right-hand side of that corridor
there's doors yeah like hotel rooms
which essentially did you open them to
be nothing there because yeah yeah but
like I never even tweaked on that the
first however many times I watched it go
well I wasn't watching it that
attentively I was watching it like oh
this is cool like whatever blah blah and
then I said bye why do I find this so
strange yeah
you know and the office is well where he
does the interview yeah there's a window
behind the manager um even though we can
clearly see before he walks in here that
there's a corridor behind there yeah so
it's like how is this working another
one like massively stands out is when
Jack goes into the red bathroom behind
the bar yeah the fact that the bar like
overlaps the the bathroom cubicles and
it just completely messes with the
feeling of space that you have for the
entire like surrounding and it just
makes you really uneasy but you don't
know why yeah it's my belt I can't think
of another film where that's been done
to that extent and they've deliberately
done it as well it's yeah because like
they don't know how to explain something
like they've like set out to make this
just mess with your head yeah and
purposely not explain it so you kind of
watching it and you don't know what's
weird about it but you just know
something is like a subconscious thought
thing and you really got to study the
film to kind of to see it um another
thing that you kind of really have to
study is all of the reflections that
Kubrick yes throughout objects
characters like the twin daughters a lot
of the environments there they're
perfectly mirror like the the maze when
yeah every time a ghost appears there's
a mirror at some ganked even when Jack's
walking towards the Gold Room he lashes
out every time he passes a reflective
surface and there's this real focus on
mirrors and throughout the entire layout
of the hotel and the the symmetry sort
of to me it symbolizes that there's this
another layer to everything there's
there's a opposite to everything that
you're not quite seeing yeah all right
yeah like afterlife yeah yeah like a
dark reflection exactly so like cuz I
noticed that when he's walking to the
Gold Room like that's one that I picked
up myself I mean obviously it's
explained on other videos and articles
and I was looking at it I was like ah
[ __ ] every time he kinda he goes man
it's when he's in front of the mirror
because he'd like to take three steps
does it three steps does it German and
like I picked up on that and then I was
like okay and then like you say there's
mirrors at you because there's symmetry
and then there's mirrors and they're
kind of used the way they it feels like
they used is to oppose each other yeah
so like this like like I said like that
darker foot because I know there's a bit
with the mirror in the dead the room
that they're staying in where like he's
lying on the bed then it's reflected but
it's really only it's like a really
uneasy scene yeah and he's been really
weird like he's not behind you guys I'm
feeling that one of those characters
isn't there that one of them's talking
to their reflection or their psyche well
it's just like the way the characters
interact with one another there's always
is uneasy feeling that they might be
hallucinating the entire thing well I
read that I didn't read it's a lie I
watched a theory recently have you seen
because like I had to turn it off in the
end because it was just so much nonsense
have you seen the shining coat
oh no I haven't no right it's worth a
watch because it's funny but like he
literally goes whoever this bloke is I
can't remember his name he's like right
okay so Danny and Jack are two versions
of the same person and relax Stanley
Kubrick and Wendy is Stanley Kubrick's
wife and then he just cuts into the next
thing it wasn't explained like what he
means by that but he's like heard that
theory that static Kubrick was gone
through a divorce at the time so this
film saw the summation of that yeah it's
I was just like well you've not
explained that but he goes mental in it
but some of these theory videos are well
funny it's like he goes back in the Oh
penny yeah yeah he goes in the opening
shot yeah when you see like that lake
and the mountain and the roads on the
side it goes oh well if you look at the
lake it mirrors the sky it's like well
well yeah but if you look at the lake it
makes an a and it's like whoa that's
just kind of well like that's the lake
that's where the valley
so he like drawers would like Microsoft
Paint this a and he goes are that a that
means that the it's a reflection of
there's a big event happening up in the
sky that begins with an a so obviously
that's the Apollo moon London that's the
biggest lie ever heard the Apollo moon
landing Theory just kind of never it's
one of the theories that I've just never
been able to agree with basically the
Apollo 11 jump that Danny where's they
they kind of get from that that Kubrick
film the Apollo moon landing yeah you
see the things with the carpet though is
kind of it's not saying that Kubrick
film moon well you can tell that Kubrick
didn't film the moon landing because
there was no hidden meaning in the moon
landing you know there's far too many
floors in the shop where he's sitting
playing with his toys on the carpet the
way the carpet is set out it's in like a
I don't know what the word is for
six-sided she's not the hexagons five
isn't it we call it a hexagon but like
so like he sat and he's like play and
he's got his rocket jumper on I think
and then he's in the middle and then
he's playing with like fire engines and
ambulances and stuff but it the way it's
set out is the same as if you look at a
photo of the Apollo I launch yeah the
layout which I could understand like
that that could be intentional that to
me it doesn't mean that he filmed the
moon one no I mean but like the other
thing with the Apollo 11 jumper fits in
with I know we said we're gonna come
into it later but it fits into the the
child abuse okay well okay we can talk
about that now it's a child abuse
subscribers and so the theory is that
the bear at the end given the [ __ ]
symbolizes that jock molest Danny and it
was a dog originally in the book but
Kubrick
deliberately chose
now most of the research I got from this
was from Rob ager
yes his channel collective learning
Callay of learning what the hell are you
still doing here go watch his video it's
better than this yeah definitely check
out his video so is amazing the bear
theme throughout really repeats Danny at
the start of the movie wakes up next to
a teddy pillow yeah and Rob actually
went back and looked at the original
catalog for the teddy and the eyes and
that were really round oh the bear won
in the film the eyes are really crumpled
it looks like they've been caught and
it's a yeah they look more sinister and
then the doctors looking into Danny's
eyes which is obviously bringing up the
importance of eyes for that scene yeah
Jack at the start who with his job
interview he's reading a magazine and
Playgirl magazine yeah incest in front
of his boss on the first day in a hotel
lobby impression Bob yeah why wouldn't
you read that article situation it's
like yaks I seen that and it's from a
few years earlier as well yeah so it's
not likely been chosen yeah it's not
like it's that you know the latest
I mean why Playgirl would be in a hotel
lobby anyway I don't know but like it's
obviously been picked and chosen right
well we'll put this in there and it
takes some research to find that out
yeah it's obviously it's not clear
enough on saving on blu-ray it's not
it's very hard to see yeah but then
obviously people have found that cover
and it's like oh yeah incest why do
parents sleep with their children think
is the name of the article yeah and the
same way we approach Danny when he's
leaning over the sink is the same way
that we approach the woman in the bath
in room 237 the shower curtain is
exactly the same it's a room that we
know Danny got abused in and Jack
thought he was kissing someone in there
during the kiss when Jackson 237 Danny's
also having a seizure which kind of
alludes to this when Wendy comes up to
Jack in the bar she says that there's
someone in the room and
and Jack just replies are you out of
your [ __ ] mind because he knows it's
not true cuz he's the one who did the
yeah yeah and do you think he goes to
basically what Rob said was he goes to
sleep and his in his drunkenness he has
a nightmare in which he's Danny and he's
being abused and that's why then returns
to see Wendy and Danny like nothing's
gone wrong with the first time I saw the
film I remember laughing at that scene
because like he's just been through this
horrific thing and then he turns back
and like what was there anyone there's
like no didn't see which it sort of
might be you know significant to how
children kind of cover up abuse
sometimes and they just say nothing's
happened do you think that I you know
that scene with the woman yeah you think
like the whole dream theory do you think
it was a dream what you think it
happened I think this happened I think
was a ghost and but Jack's so
intertwined in the hotel that he just
denies that had happened yeah cuz like I
I when I first heard about the dream
theory I was like right okay because you
see Danny um he's like shaking yeah and
I was like right it's Danny projecting
it's he's shining now and projecting
that into Jack's head so that Jack sees
that hmm you know I mean and I was like
oh I don't know
tsunami cuz I thought I was a ghost at
first I thought it was part of the hotel
and I need just denies it because he's
because he's part of the hotel yeah you
know potentially but like once like once
I heard that dream theory I was like ah
[ __ ] right okay yeah you know just make
sense definitely as a dream and then the
whole Toby thing as well mmhmm yeah
check not Toby Tony sorry Tony but I
call Tony Montana little little tiny
Tony his little finger friend the
choppers they'd say hello and my little
finger friend would be so different if
the whole film was about a child's
finger that comes in sells cocaine in
America I think that should be that that
should be the remake there's three you
make it should be little
we Montana yeah but yeah like the whole
Tony like the imaginary-friend think
like once I knew about the abuse theory
I was like right is Tony Jack's knob
yeah it's that when open his mouth
doesn't and doesn't want to talk about
it you can't see him yeah cuz he goes in
his belly yeah exactly and there are
lots of things and again with the bear
theme as there's a picture of bears that
hang above Danny's bed and the naked
children that mimic the Bears yeah
exactly
there's bears throughout the entire film
there's a big bearskin rug in the main
hall and oh yeah you've every time
something bad happens there's always
sort of a bear around another thing that
plays in the background is there's a
sticker of dopey and on the side of the
back I'm so glad
jinda yeah after after he gets his
vision of the hotel at the start
Danny that for some reason the dopey
sticker disappears
yeah which could imply that Danny's no
longer dopey to the world yeah and he
knows what's going on now it's the
growth of his ability um and it's also
symbolized by the fact that he's riding
a tricycle on the bottom floor and then
the next time we see him he's on the
next floor which is where yams sees room
to 237 and he's just constantly
elevating himself
um and that little sticker symbolizes
quite a lot and you can clearly see it
against the bathroom door and then in
the next scene it's gone yeah and that's
you wouldn't you wouldn't start filming
a film and then go oh you know what I
make this better let's put some seven
dwarf stickers on the doorjamb I mean so
it's obviously intentionally done and
filmed that way round yeah exactly
it's it like because that whole like
sticker thing I've mentioned that so
like a couple of like I know of a few
people who like the film and not quite
to the point where you kind of study it
but I've mentioned that and then
straight when they've gone I
okay like that's that I think that's the
one thing that kind of resonates with a
lot of people they're like right he's
not a dope anymore I got it you know and
then yeah like this the thing is as well
with because you don't see the dopey bit
the dopey sticker you know when he's
talking to the psychiatrist and yemm's
lying on his bed
the door is next to Wendy and you can
see the bathroom but you can't see the
door with the stickers on yeah so like
once he's talking about that it's
removed then like even though you can't
see it to see that it's been taken down
it's actually not in frame so yeah again
like that's something that I picked up
more recently when oh it could obviously
like he's talking about Toni and stuff
like that and he's lying there with no
pants on with his hands kind of covering
his his groin area yeah which again
really really does heavily yeah yeah
hint towards the the abuse thing but
going back to the Apollo jumper
that's really really phallic yeah
definitely which again I didn't know
it's that first time until I started hit
like reading and hearing about the the
abuse theory that was when I know it's
the rocketjump a sample that looks like
a dick to me yeah like that you know
having an image your mind does kind of
come in useful when analyzed in the most
complex films of all time having an
immature mind does help sometimes
they're like yeah so like he's wearing a
jumper and then it the jumper changes
and it's ripped and his collars ripped
and he's wearing the Apollo one and it
does look like a dick pulling in towards
his mouth yeah and also when Jack falls
over laughter over this nightmare like a
load of like spit comes out of his mouth
yeah which is anyway yeah like obviously
people drool when they say but it's just
a bit too much for it to be on
indefinitely like a sign of something
you know
yeah hundred percent hundred percent and
and going more into this sort of
disturbing side of things
I love how the ghosts aren't scary in
the game they just appear as people yeah
a very very sinister side to them that
the scares are very very subtle there's
no real jump scares in it and there's
disappear in chairs throughout the film
but they're always in the background and
just lets you know that there's
something wrong like this it's sort of
the rumors of the Qbert just messing
about with the set all the time when
they weren't shooting and moving things
about so that when it does have a cut
you this an object will move and you'll
not quite pick up on it but it'll be in
your subconscious and that's what
Kubrick does brilliantly oh yeah the two
main ghosts in it the twins there they
sort of have a blue dress and it only
noticed it very recently the shape of
their blue dress is the same shape of
the seat of Danny's tricycle so when
he's riding that along if you squint it
also looks like he's wearing a blue
dress as well but also that's the exact
same dress that Wendy is wearing okay
you know when Danny's lying on the bed
yeah and after he's brushing his teeth
she's wearing a blue dress with red like
a red top underneath and Danny is
wearing a red jumper with the blue seat
to mimic I don't know whether it's
mimicking his mom or the twins or both
or whether him and his mom or this
events version of the two twins in the
blue dresses yeah maybe yeah because
like it like it's like that mirroring
thing again because there is a sort of
feeling of reincarnation throughout the
film yeah Delbert Grady is the the sort
of main highlight of this he's very
clearly calls himself Delbert Grady in
the bathroom but at the start
he's called Charles Grady by the manager
yeah there's a theory of reincarnation
which explains how Jack was able to be
in the 1921 photo is a there's basically
Grady and Jack sort of switch
so one becomes the caretaker when
Torrance is like either just died or
he's growing up so he's not able to like
be a hotel caretaker and they sort of
intertwine with one another and take
over each other's roles and it also
explains how sometimes the twins are
twins and sometimes they're different
ages like the manager of the stock
clearly says that the twin they're the
girls were eight and ten yeah even
though they're definitely twins in it's
this nice sort of subversion of
expectation you get told one thing by
one character and then the next time
when you see them in reality there's
there's a difference of them but it's
subtle thing as well so it's again
creating confusion while you watch like
I'm gone I thought his name was Charles
great Charles Grady not Delbert yeah
like that that whole like you say that
that reincarnation of Charles becoming
Delbert so is he did Delbert go there
after Charles did is he related to him
so did he go there and then or is he
just literally a reincarnation as a
ghost or or what but like when I first
watched that I didn't pick up on the
name changes it's only like a bit later
on I was like I'm sure he said his name
was Charles Grady what have I got
Charles yeah and then you know like I
mean there's like like the twins things
like he says that's when it says they're
eight in ten then you look at me like
I'm sure they're twins yeah I know it's
referred to like culturally as twins
yeah you know like it definitely are the
twins from the shining I don't know in
real life if they are you know really
yeah because I'm sure I remember see I'm
gonna should we have a little quick look
now about Delbert Grady and how how
polite I love how like tying back to the
sinister side of the ghost Delbert Grady
he's really polite but you can clearly
tell there's like something wrong there
I mean he's cleaning jack up and then
he's just he never says he murdered his
daughters he just says I correct
I corrected them yeah yeah and when he
starts suggesting that Jack killed his
families like you've got a very naughty
boy if you don't mind me saying so which
is quite funny like he says a couple of
times if you don't mind me saying so
it's like way of like scaring someone
they are twins in real life right okay
yeah they're both like 50 now so now
okay boy yeah like that the TEL I like
the year that Delbert Grady character
when he says you've always been the
caretaker I should know sir I've always
been here yeah it's like it's so creepy
the way he says it why do you think it's
because I don't cut away and his
expression doesn't really break and he
says it with such conviction yeah and
it's just yeah it's very very creepy but
without being like an insidious type of
movie yeah jump scares all the time and
like the stuff like I've read recently
about a lot of modern Horrors like your
insidious and your conjuring soils that
those sort of studios they use a base
tone that's really really really low
that you can't hear you can only feel it
yeah so when they want you to feel tense
and anxious and nervous about something
this base tone is played so you can feel
it in so you feel dodgy in like your
stomach and your chest but you don't
know why yeah which is a really clever
technique if it is true I don't never
made a film I don't know but I can
imagine that's the sort that neat they
would use but what I like about the
shining so much compared to those sort
of films is the jump scares don't exist
and the tension comes from the layout of
the set that the storyline itself the
characters that the the little things
like old-school filmmaking like how do
we confuse people without letting them
know that they're confused yeah we'll
just change little things suddenly but
like all of these confusion things they
all fit into all these different mad fan
theories as well exactly yeah in another
one which kind of ties in with Alva
Grady because he drops the N bomb a
couple of times yeah is the undercurrent
of racism within
they'll and Jack very heavily says when
he's drinking it's the white man's but
white man's beard in yeah yeah I mean
there's an Indian heritage mosaics on
hanging walls Indian chants I'm sure you
can hear an Indian chant during the
radio conversation between Wendy and the
police officer oh really oh yeah it's
very but once you notice it it's
definitely there the Indian theories one
of the ones I'm most interested in yeah
and this chant sounds like when you
collect coins onto rock very very clear
that's kind of reminded me of I like the
Indian theory because I know that they
mentioned at the very beginning when
they're talking about the is it the
Donna family and the cannibalism thing
yeah I've been there in the car and then
they mention that the hotel is on an old
Indian burial ground yeah and then
there's obviously like within that like
once I knew about that failure I was
like well that's bollocks why why would
he do a film about a hotel and a guy
killed his family to link it to like
Indians but I don't think it's obviously
a full representation of it but then
those lines do fit in
there's too much for it to be
coincidence yeah I'm like the Indian
stuff everywhere but then there's like
the cultural disrespect like when he's
throwing the ball around the room and he
should get really angry he throws the
ball at the like a huge Indians a mosaic
mural thing on the wall as massive and
then what I noticed as well and it took
me a long time to pick up on it he's the
red white and blue thing okay where's
that I haven't actually seen that well
he wears red white and blue
Danny wears red white and blue and Wendy
was Confederate colors yeah and when he
walks into the rooms that are like it
when he walks into the interviews like a
little American flag when he's talking
to the manager and yeah when he kind of
goes mad like as well what he's what
he's wearing like there Danny and Wendy
are wearing red white and blue quite
prominently you know like it's very
obvious like primary colors are bright
blue bright red
prymakova something remember but then
like Jax of a lot darker yeah so like
he's sure is like a navy with like white
check on it and then his jacket is like
a big Andy sort of red so it's like the
dark red white and blue so like the dark
side of America and yeah stuff like that
and that when he's being violent and
those are the scenes where you kind of
can pick up on it a lot more
yeah well the that clearly there's an
Indian food can yeah it almost looks
like product placement the way that's
just kind of placed in there yeah and
the tagline used for the film aren't on
its release was the wave of terror that
swept across America yes room 237
discusses how it symbolizes the genocide
of the American Indians the faden's
throughout the shining are also so long
that they create a super imposition yeah
there's a bit we're right at the start
that the forest sort of fades into the
hotel lobby and I mean it's a three or
four second fade and it looks like the
janitors sweeping up the forest
yeah which sort of symbolizes like clean
in the ground yeah Danny also retraces
his steps later in the maze which is
supposed to sort of symbolize retracing
your history and there's so Wendy
throughout the entire film just like
dresses in Indian clothes she's caught
yeah oh that has teepees on and that the
air about the tassels the yeah pictured
on it and stuff yeah and she just yeah I
mean the Indian thing to me it's it's
clear as day another one that sort of
ties in with the racism is the Holocaust
theory in which I'm not too sure about
what's you sure on that area in room 237
basically they say that the German
typewriter that Jack uses symbolizes the
typewriter that was used to
industrialize the killing of the Jews
yeah during the Holocaust
it's got the word Adler on it and an
eagle which obviously that that's both
things that we
by the Nazis and there's the several
Eagles throughout the film yeah in the
manager's office on t-shirts and you
know these are meant to symbolize the
government's controlling of killing and
the typewriter actually changes color
throughout to say that the change of
color yeah which sort of you should
really be giving attention to it and but
yeah it's I'm not too sure and I think
yeah I think one kind of the India one
for me stands out a lot more and makes a
lot more sense yeah definitely and to be
that I like I like quite a few it like a
few of the theories like which is your
favorite theory and probably the Indian
one and it's not really a theory but
just the the hotel layout yeah I mean
every scene has an impossibility in it
almost yeah Danny watches his TV at one
point that doesn't have a cord yeah it's
not doing anything he's just sitting
watching TV there's a little bit where
the hotel lobby at the start the the
luggage that the family you've brought
it there's so much of it it's like 15
people's where this yes isn't it there's
no way they could have got it all in the
car there's a point where they're
getting their tour of the hotel and they
go across a road and a car is literally
just about to hit them and it cuts and
the next shot they're like walking along
in the car passes them yeah
and it's sort of that there's a real
dark sense of humor that Kubrick has and
that's why his films are so fascinating
they're The Shining is almost comedic in
like a really dark way and a lot of the
lines that Jack gets are you know that
they could be laughed at well yeah and
obviously they were when the Simpsons
did it
yeah the Wendy Darling light in my life
yeah exactly yeah so funny that it makes
me laugh now even though I know that I
shouldn't laugh at it it's yeah you know
he's about to try and kill his wife not
great but it is quite funny at the same
time yeah and do you think that Jack has
the shining himself now see
I do because when Danny and Wendy are in
the maze Jack's just standing and
staring out into the garden and there's
the shine sound effect mmm and I think
that drinking made him lose it so when
he was drunk getting drunk all the time
he lost his like ability to shine and
then from not drinking he regains it and
that's why I can start to see ghosts in
the hotel room yeah theory I like that
the whole film the owner and it's a like
a metaphor for his alcoholism yeah and
one of the the main things that I think
kind of confirms that he has this
psychic connection with Danny is he's
throwing the ball at the wall yeah and
then the same ball rolls out of the room
at 2:37 so it's kind of like he's
beckoning Danny and yeah so it's I I do
take it as he he's got this power as
well and he's passed on to his son and
the hotel's kind of brought it out in
him
that's a cool I never I've never felt a
bit like that because I always kind of
looked at it like nah I always kind of
thought like well Jack hasn't got the
shine in yeah I don't change your mind
well I'm gonna edit it yeah I'm gonna
watch it again with that in mind
yeah and trying to think about that and
like excuse to re-watch the shining and
you're on it apparently this happened in
one scene there's like a book on the
side all right I'll watch the whole film
again yeah I like the alcoholism theory
that's one of the theories that's quite
new to me like there because there's
obviously there's mentions of him being
a recovering alcoholic and you know when
he mentions I got I'd give my my goddamn
soul for a glass of beer
yeah and the white man's burden of the
same scene as the white man's burden and
and that and that's when he meets
Delbert as well exactly yeah
and that's when things for him start to
get more and more confusing
yeah it's grateful
is there anything that else you want to
talk about I mean I do have notes on the
the [ __ ] doll with the the blood red
shirt um being similar to Halloran how
he's murdered but nothing that really
jumps out at me I mean I don't want to
cover it's also it's like what you know
about the labyrinthian theory as well no
no what's that so basically like the
Haute like in I know in the book there
was no maze just tell them there's no
mayor's big garden hedge docks and yeah
yeah that was terrible and then we make
there was no actual maze and stuff and
like one of the theories is that it's
basically leading towards the bats the
labyrinth ran the code
the jack is the mine at all okay it's
like it's it links in with like the
whole film being like a cycle of death
so it's like just death repeating death
repeating death of the air I can't
remember the name of the guy in Greek
mythology that defeats the mind at all
it was either Theseus or Perseus think
maybe in Theseus I think it might have
been Theseus only there was a way we
could find out instantly so I'll let you
google that but well yeah so like it's
basically saying that Jack is the
Minotaur yeah Danny is will go with
Theseus who defeats the magnet or by yes
yes nice one so like by doing that he
breaks the cycle of death okay um I also
like the isolation the isolation part of
it like the solid like the solitude of
Hell and wherever because like at the
beginning when Jack's having his meeting
with the manager and he mentions about
the isolation and being lonely and stuff
what does he say I come home that I've
got notes because I've written down the
exact thing he says I don't know me
find it now but he basically says that
he's okay with it yeah
and in my head I'm like right
is he okay with it because he's fine
with the isolation because he wants to
try and get himself back on track he
wants to ride he wants some time in Pitt
space by himself or is he okay with it
because he knows what he's going there
to do yeah and the ice
the isolation allows him to do that
because who knows no one's going to be
able to interfere because no one can get
there yeah and like people are at their
worst when they're isolated so 100% yeah
so well yeah and no as well in that
because obviously brings out the worst
of him but awesome it brings out the
best in Wendy and Danny
so although all the bad things happen in
that film when people are on their own
yeah so so like Jack goes into room 237
something bad happens he's there by
himself Danny comes down he's as far as
we're over here by himself and all these
different things that happened because
people are there by themselves but with
Danny and Wendy it's the opposite so
like isolation brings out the best in
him because like Wendy because like
brave and quick thinking you know
chucking Danny through the window taking
him on with a knife whatever it locking
him and she locks him in the in the
kitchen in that room in the kitchen she
locks the door and locked him in yeah
yeah all these quick thinking things and
then Danny's obviously brave but he runs
away from Jack Annie retraces his own
steps to hide to confuse him like that's
quick thinking but he's always it's
always when they're by themselves that
they do that yeah that's correct yeah
and I quite like that it's not even a
theory it's just that aspect of it is
like the isolation aspect I really like
that's really good thing I'd never even
thought of that before yeah so anything
else you want to talk about all em I
know you've probably got loads and loads
who want to say I've got all sorts of
stuff but it's like do you have any
problems with the film no because the
things that I thought were problems I
like that they're there because they
make me think about certain things you
I've had a couple of them I think
there's a couple of big-time jumps that
where you basically getting it to other
hotel and then it jumps ahead and a bit
which I know obviously Kubrick probably
wanted to do but just looking at it from
more of a conventional movie point of
view and there's a bit where Halloran's
talking with Danny about The Shining and
then literally just jumps and one of one
of the funny things I think about it is
that Jack Nicholson is pretty much
always called Jack and I'll never know
why it reminds me a bit of Keith Chegwin
when he did it that sketch in there
extras he had to be called Keith Keith
yeah like sometimes Nicholson Acton's a
bit over the top like we've discussed
there's a there's a great comedic edge
to it yeah you know he does a really
good job that the here's Johnny scene is
just phenomenal like it's it's so famous
as well and just because of his
performance it's so well done and I love
when he just has little smirks
throughout the film and he looks at the
camera sometimes but very looks at the
camera really freaks me out yeah was he
there watching him yeah like he argues
with Wendy and then he walks out doesn't
he out of the rear and he like glances
but his face is so like aggressive yeah
it's like the slightest glance of the
camera the camera incidentally is what
would be pretty much in Danny's bedroom
doorway yeah it would have to be and he
like glances so is he looking at also is
he looking at Danny and it's so angry
and so soul because I didn't even know
is it the first couple of times and then
afterwards I was like well looked at
they cover their music but like that's
obviously intentional as well because
Jack Nicholson you know wouldn't look at
the camera
let you know in the most simplest terms
he's not a [ __ ] up there is it yeah I
mean so he would know you don't have to
tell Jack Nicholson don't look at the
camera
Pyrrhic wouldn't stand for someone
looking at it so it's obviously intent
and for a reason and is he letting you
know that he knows you're watching yeah
is he angry roars is he angry Danny is
he Judah I mean and there's all these
different like every little thing could
have so many meanings and possibilities
no hundred percent I tell you who I do
think was a [ __ ] actor and Shelley
Duvall I really don't like her in this
film no one does
yeah she pretty much did nothing after
this but play olive oil and Popeye and I
think Kubrick just broke her down yeah
she struggled she had like a lot of
things she took a lot of time out after
the film cuz I know what I did like it
sounds really cruel but what I do like
is that as the film goes on her
performance gets more and more drained
because obviously that happens to the
character but also because it literally
happened to her and you know you can
literally see it in her face she
literally cannot be [ __ ] asked
anymore what's going on yeah and that
kind of ties into the film so well you
know like how like the actual look of
fear on her face when smashing through
the door and she stood behind it in that
and then when he's like trying to come
up the stairs if she's swinging in the
back because they were like take 170 on
him yeah and she just looked so
exhausted and like I agreed like no I
don't particularly like her in that film
a boy I don't think the film would be
the same with a different actress yeah I
totally get that another person who had
all the takes was Scatman Crothers
obviously I kind of don't like how he
plays the cliched mystical black guy I
comment but that was meant to be given
to somebody else first thing in horror
movies where you always got the mystical
black person and I do kind of think it's
a bit cliched but you know Scatman
Crothers he did get the Guinness Book of
World Records and for the most takes
ever which just looking it up it was a
hundred and forty-eight takes for the
scene where he talks to Danny in the
kitchen Wow
well done yeah Tony's also a bit of a
nonentity and I think ya come full
circle almost like that in that it kind
of gets fitted in like it gets swept
under the carpet so if that's a
representation of the child abuse yeah
that kind of sweeping it under the
carpet so it's like a it kind of mirrors
that if you know I mean yeah I do a
great and I obviously I loved the movie
in the things I'm nitpicking are more
from a sort of conventional movie goer
point of view I've got one friend who
thinks this is the worst movie ever made
yeah that may be argue just watch it
just watch it please how do you think it
ended what you think the ending is what
he means I really don't know to be
honest I do kind of like they're just
the horrifying frozen corpse
um burry don't know in the book Danny
escapes um and he he graduates and then
sees Tony off in the distance and he
realizes that Tony's an older version of
himself right okay does something like
that but what do you think of the ending
I think I meet these days I'm leaning
towards the absorbs or ssin I can't even
say the word absorption theory so
basically I saw Jack gets absorbed in
the hotel
yeah so what he's not been there before
he knows it's like the reincarnation of
people keep going there and getting
sucked in so like he goes and that's why
that photo from 1921 I think it is
that's why it's in that photo because if
it's sucked into the hotel and he's
become part of it and I like yeah like
the I like the fact he doesn't
technically die he just freezes yeah so
it's like the whole frozen in time and
then I like that and I like the the
repetition within the film so like that
all work and no play repetition it's
just the same thing over and over and
over again with a few little bits where
it goes a bit wonky but it's the same
thing which reflects there that the you
know the overlap the
overlapping theme of the whole film is a
repetition yeah you know people before
him have gone there done the exact same
thing yeah no that's that's what I like
to think it is in the minute you know
ask me in six months when I watch it
it's totally different times I'm like oh
no it's definitely the moon London you
know means it says it cuz he's got the
Apollo jumper on how can it mean
anything else yeah yeah that's what
that's what I'm lying within the minute
is that he gets sucked into the hotel
yeah and I think I kind of do agree with
that but a lot of reincarnation thing as
well I don't know there's so much
there's so much going on but that's what
I like about it is that all of them fit
yeah so gnarly well yeah you can make
five hour videos discussing every single
point probably yeah like that guy does
yeah yeah but thanks very much for
checking out the first episode of
greatest movie ever bent makes you wanna
shout out any of your projects or
Twitter em just a pet likes on
everything pretty much no ongoing
projects that I want to shout out
because none of them are close enough to
be finished and I probably end up
dropping her my way through so that'd be
pointless yeah yeah I'd like a shout out
my granddad William Bruce who sadly
passed away at the weekend he had a
really beautiful death and I'm really
lucky to have had him in my life and the
family greatly miss him so yeah thanks
for the great years you gave us we've
kind of been trying to record this
podcast quite a few times but
something's always came up yeah and I'm
glad that we finally got fun doing this
thanks everyone for taking time to
listen in the episode as well anything
you want to say bent legs before we go
cheers mate to you as well I love
another one it's the white man's burden